He's mingled with witches and done battle
with vampires — it's clear that The Last
Kingdom's Alexander Dreymon has a
knack for spellbinding spectacle.
Netflix's ninth-century costume drama The Last
Kingdom was adapted from the successful Saxon
Stories series of historical adventure novels
from renowned English author Bernard Cornwell.
Originally produced by BBC Two in the U.K. and
BBC America in the US, Netflix became the sole
producer of the series from Season 3 onward –
stepping up to foot the show's substantial bill.
The books — and show — follows the
exploits of Uhtred of Bebbanburg,
the dispossessed scion of a noble house in
the ancient English kingdom of Northumbria.
The Saxon Stories book series currently sits at
13 entries, with the final installment hitting
shelves back in 2020. This proved fortunate
for Netflix, as The Last Kingdom adapted
Cornwell's books at a respectable pace,
chewing up about two novels per season.
"I gave you glory!
I gave you the freedom to worship your God,
and still you treat me no better than a hound."
Uhtred is played by Alexander Dreymon — and if
you think his handsome visage looks
familiar, there's a very good reason.
According to IMDb, Alexander Dreymon was born in
Germany, though he lived for some time in France,
and moved to England to study at
the prestigious Drama Centre London,
which permanently closed its doors in 2022.
He earned his thespian stripes performing on
the stage in both Paris and London before
making the jump to television and film.
Dreymon's first major role on American television
was as a recurring character on the third season
of the popular American Horror Story anthology
series. Dreymon played the part of Luke Ramsey,
appearing on five episodes of the witchy
Coven storyline. The son of the Christian
Joan Ramsey — played by Patti LuPone — who
lives next door to Miss Robichaux's Academy,
Luke mixes in with the witches studying and
living there. However, his religious beliefs
cause him a great deal of inner turmoil. In the
end — after getting literally stabbed in the back,
shot through the head, and put into a
coma — Luke is murdered by his mother,
which follows his realization
that she killed Luke's father.
"God told me you put the bees in the car.
You knew dad was allergic to bees.
You knew you'd get away with it"
The role of Luke Ramsey introduced a
clean-shaven Dreymon to American audiences,
and made it abundantly clear that the actor
had both the talent and charisma to continue
his ascent into becoming a leading man for
any sized screen. It wasn't long after his
American Horror Story debut that Dreymon really
began exploring the world of feature films.
One year before he was cast in the leading
role of Uhtred on The Last Kingdom, and one
year following his turn on American Horror Story,
Dreymon starred in the vampire romance thriller,
Blood Ransom. He played the part of Jeremiah,
heading up a cast that also included Clifton
Powell, Jamie Harris, and Emily Skinner.
Dreymon seemingly proved his ability to
hold an entire production on his ample
shoulders, because it wasn't long after
Blood Ransom that he was snatched up
by the producers of The Last Kingdom.
"Don't be afraid."
"I'm not."
While Dreymon continued to demonstrate his range
by appearing in two more feature-length films —
the 2016 mystery Guys Reading Poems and the 2019
romantic crime-drama Heartlock – he was already an
established name with a busy production schedule
thanks to the success of The Last Kingdom.
Now, the future's looking bright for Dreymon,
who recently appeared in the Swedish thriller
Horizon Line. The film also stars
Get Out actress Allison Williams,
with whom, in reality, Dreymon shares
a son and is romantically engaged.
As Uhtred is fond of reminding us,
"destiny is all," and it certainly
seems like Dreymon was destined
for stardom from the beginning.